an eight-year see the jerk Steve Martin
movie classic of race I have the new
Chromebooks are here the new Chromebooks
are here I finally feel like somebody
it's a beautiful thing have bad
reference anyway we have the new google
chromebook it's called the pixel google
announced it on thursday at a small
event in san francisco it's going on
sale in a couple of weeks yep or
pre-order is available today it's
shipping in a couple of months shipping
in April April yup early April and
unlike other chrome books which were she
already glass she wondered two hundred
fifty dollars this one costs thirteen
hundred dollars or $1,500 thirteen
hundred dollars to the Wi-Fi only
version $1,500 if you want some Verizon
4G LTE capability but then you got to
buy a data plan right yeah so it's a
like other chrome books that have come
before and that it runs Chrome OS it
doesn't have a real operating system on
it has an instance of the browser so you
open it up and everything's in the cloud
you sign me the Google potentials and it
is unlike every other Chromebook that
has come before because it's built
entirely by Google there's no hardware
partners explicit hardware partners
they're the OEM on this or they said
they were the odm yeah basically they
worked with other suppliers they
designed it and then they got someone in
China or Taiwan to manufacture it for
him and it's a high-end machine
everything about a tie-in it's awesome
it's got a touchscreen which is really
cool never seen that before in a
Chromebook it has a 3.2 aspect ratio
with an incredibly dense denser than
retina display dense yeah yeah very very
very tight all around really really nice
we're super impressed with the hardware
yeah it really feels like this is the
Chromebook that I've always wanted I use
a Chromebook almost every day I only
really turn on my macbook pro if I'm
using Adobe you know photoshop
illustrator or from using Final Cut Pro
which doesn't happen as often nowadays
and but those old Chromebooks they were
cheap and they're plasticky and this
kind of underpowered also i felt like
yeah this thing is screaming fast p
never really been super happy with the
track pads yep the track but on here is
gorgeous it's made of glass the
touchscreen is beautiful I mean this
feels like really nice yeah this feels
like the laptop I've wanted to carry
around as a Chromebook but I mean it
would have been nicer feels maybe like a
thousand dollars 900 bucks we're not
being said it's kind of cutting-edge
stuff in the sense of the touch display
actually seems to work pretty nice yeah
it does it's uh it's I've I've been
playing with it we've both been playing
with them for a couple hours at this
point and the screen really is just
stunning it's gorgeous it's really nice
but you know at that price point I think
they're not trying to attract the story
that Google was always telling about the
previous Chromebook is like students yes
you know high schools college students a
second computer in your home a third
computer your home this is for a power
user somebody who really wants like the
the Balboni you know the the really nice
Lamborghini instead of the Volvo yes to
get to and from because the other
computers will get you to and from just
fine this just does it in a gorgeous
package that has a much better screen
you can reach up and touch plus the
performance inside is really nice it's
got a core i5 with integrated graphics
you know scrolling web pages is very
smooth and I'm also a big fan of the the
weird aspect ratio I actually like all
your screen instead of a wider screen I
was worried about it not being a
16-point by nine sixteen by nine but it
actually fits it's really nice it's
almost 13 inches big and it just it's
beautiful I mean yeah I think I I love
this thing on on first and first
impression still gotta push through its
paces I don't love the price tag but the
hardware is gorgeous so let's talk a
little bit about what Google's trying to
do here aside from you know sort of a
proof of concept yes this is a this is
how nice a Chromebook can be let's take
the Chromebook out of the ghetto so to
speak and put it on a super super nice
piece of hardware you know maybe trying
to encourage our manufacturers to go out
and make touchscreen Chromebooks out and
compete with windows 8 machines it's
definitely part of it I mean
the chrome launch event that we are at
sundar Pichai who is the senior vice
president who oversees all things chrome
he basically said listen the future of
computing is in touch the future of
computing is in high-resolution displays
and they need to push Google needs to
push the chrome ecosystem that direction
they want to push hardware makers that
direction and they want to push
developers that direction now right now
you've had a couple years worth of cheap
you know small inexpensive laptops and
what that's done has you know you got a
lot of web apps but you don't have guys
like Adobe making a real true Photoshop
equivalent you don't have folks like
avid making you know video editing
software anything like that and just be
clear I like that may never happen it
might not but now here is a high-powered
machine with you know one of the best
displays we've ever seen it on a laptop
that might be able to court those
developers they said this is in part a
play to give them the hardware to
justify making that sort of web app
which hasn't been done before yeah and
might not ever happen but maybe it will
and it's also to give you know people
who are chrome users may be a reason or
excuse to buy that Lamborghini you know
set your ferrari macbook air to the side
and pick up this lamborghini chrome
pixel Google pixel you know we'll see if
that actually works but that's that
seems to be the general idea and the
other the other final point is Android
now they already make a operating system
that runs on a variety of touchscreen
devices that is has a gigantic install
base yeah large world so here they come
with their own hardware you know
throwing another product into the mix
that runs a different flavor of Google
operating system also based on linux so
it's free and it's open and anybody can
develop for it and and what you have for
Android and what you have here are
touchscreen apps and in some of the
touch screen apps they've shown us they
look and work just like they do on their
tablet and phone counter counterparts
that's not a mistake html5 is all about
responsive design decisions Android is
trying to push developers to design with
de-spawn civ or with responsive
technologies so that it can work on all
the different screen sizes Android is
found on there's a common theme here
maybe someday you might see Android and
from kind of becoming one maybe not who
knows but right now Google say you just
made my head spin man right now right
now Google is saying they have two
visions for computing one is mobile with
Android and one is more laptop based
here but both of those two visions that
they're both working on simultaneously
use touch mmm that's where they think
the future of computing is that we shall
see so for now it's big it's heavy it's
expensive as hell the screen is awesome
it's beautiful its sword a really nice
piece of hardware if you've got 1,300
bucks just like burning a hole in your
pocket who doesn't and it only runs a
browser and everything that's in the web
well so it sounds like a weird
proposition but I know there's several
people out there who are excited about
it we are and you can read more of
Nate's excitement on his review will to
run and wired in the coming weeks one
last thing before we go the easter egg
the konami code easter egg you have to
show that off that's pretty sweet yup up
up down down left right left right ba
and then the little LED strip here goes
through all of its colors and blanks
that's cool super cool so that's all we
have for you this week and you could
read Nate's review in a couple of weeks
on wired and until then we will see you
on the gadget lab